he's got all those qualifications but he  has committed the unpardonable sin of  being a quote CIS white male having said  that I believe that Mr delaya would make  an excellent president however I feel  that electing  the only sis white male on this board  president of this District  sends the wrong message  to our community Mrs Steinbeck has done  an exemplary job as president these last  few months and the strength of her  performance has earned her my vote  tonight they go almost to the precipice  of being somewhat honest about their  intentions and then they always pull  back at the end  she said all that about well he's a CIS  white male and so we can't vote for him  and then at the very end after  explaining that at the very end she says  well I voted for this other person  because of the strength of her  performance no that's not why you just  said you just admitted that you're  voting for this other person because of  her demographics and her identity